what's up guys lunch money time while
Wall Street rying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right I'm here with the beautiful and
intelligent plenum era Nova she's got on
a Patagonia sweatshirt I got nothing to
say about it today suddenly sweatshirt I
guess right it's like a zip up it's fine
are you mute today are you a silent
retreat
don't forget lunch money is sponsored by
block Phi they've got three products
those three products allow you to
deposit [ __ ] donor US dollar alone you
can buy and sell crypto or you can earn
up to eight point six percent interest
go in the description click on the link
sign up for an account earn eight point
six percent interest while the rest of
Wall Street is going chaos over the
stock market eight point six doesn't
sound too bad
what's up welcome to the show you do
speak um should we have your own intro
like your only intro music and you just
do one by yourself
can I advertise whatever I want no okay
what's going on but him unemployment
claims totaled 1.5 million dollars last
week compared with the 1.6 million doubt
John's estimate so basically the total
claims number has fallen for ten
straight weeks but it is still extremely
high the highest number ever before this
what think was 1982 there was like
800,000 people who filed for
unemployment claims first time in a
single week in a year
jumped remember from normal levels to
that first week about 10-12 weeks ago
when we hit three point five million
three point three miles I'm like that
then I went to six point six six point
six and it's falling pretty steadily
since then we become desensitized
everyone's a call it's like 1.5 million
decent 1.8 million people that's that's
double literally almost double the
highest ever before the last 12 weeks
it's pretty crazy
total first time unemployment claims
over 44 million to give you a sense that
means that one-third of people almost
1/3
there's about 155 million people in the
US labor force about one third of people
lost their jobs over the last three
months
only about 20-something million or
actually on the ongoing unemployment
insurance so meaning that about half of
the people who lost their jobs or for
unemployment at some point are either
employed or no longer looking for work
according to what these data points are
telling us that's crazy that's all I
have to say about it I'm sad and it's
crazy open up the economy safely and
quickly but where we're opening up the
economies does they know about my finger
you see you guys see my little finger
there's little chapped up all right uh
what's going on GrubHub when I first met
him he said he could never get married
because his finger was messed up his
ring finger I told it on the first day
of our very first date ever
why are you thinking about marriage I
just want to put you on your heels let
you know 9 in the best just eat takeaway
is this European company that recently
just got approved to March so it was
just eat and take away merged and then
they just called it just eat take away
yeah there's some creative geniuses
going on in Europe they have reached an
agreement to acquire GrubHub which is a
us-based company and because just
etakeaway does not have US operations I
guess this makes sense for them but 7.3
billion dollars that's like that seems
like extremely low to me oh I think
that's high really crap Hubbins seamless
like GrubHub own seamless so you're
basically buying GrubHub and you're
buying seamless for seven point three
million dollars entering the American
market what I don't understand is if
you're seven point eight million dollar
company how are you creating how are you
buying actually it's more of a merger
and it sounds like the new company will
be worth about fourteen billion dollars
I think it's an all-stock deal yes so
basically if they're just merchants of
two companies together and they create a
pretty big business with 70 million
customers combined globally I don't know
what the logic is for the European
company to buy the American company to
enter the US market yeah but like they
just got through the approvals in the UK
will they allow that here in the United
States I don't know if there's going to
be
I trust issues also ubereats well but do
you remember that there were rumors at
uber wanted to buy GrubHub that was kind
of considered antitrust because that
would create well the whole thing comes
there's only so many players in the
market right there's GrubHub which owns
seamless so GrubHub is one company
you've got you buried you got door -
yeah and that's pretty much it the u.s.
right maybe caviar there's a couple of
other ones small ones close mates
whatever but for the most part like the
market is dominated by GrubHub and buy
right and so like what ends up happening
when you get consolidation people too
are like yeah is that anti-competitive
right by the way I don't think it is but
you know how government is they like
metal in all of ya hey grab hub see must
call us we use you every day love it
ordered so burritos tacos anymore
margaritas little liquid diet for you I
was gonna broad James LeBron James NBA
superstar LeBron James and a group of
other prominent black athletes and
entertainers are starting a new group
aimed at protecting African Americans
voting rights seizing on this is the
longest sentence I've ever seizing on
the widespread fury against racial
injustice that has filled worldwide
protests so basically he's gonna help
people like go vote way to protect their
right to vote because there's all kinds
of voting suppression things that happen
so they redraw districts they basically
make it really difficult for you to get
to the voting booth all kinds of
different stuff you know why I like
LeBron James like LeBron James is one of
the only athletes in the world in
history who had that much pressure and
that much yeah you're going to be the
greatest in the world at 16 years old
and he had one minor incident when he
was in high school and it was really not
him that did anything he was more around
a local business owner gave him like
some jerseys or something but ever since
that day there have been nothing that's
a pretty minor incident yeah and it
wasn't like anything that was like no
Arius or anything like that like
literally somebody gave him you know a
gift basically and he got in trouble for
it and he's marrying his high-school
sweetheart he's never had a scandal not
nothing and like the biggest knock you'd
have against the guy is like maybe he
post like stupid stuff on social media
that's very like braggadocious or
something like the decision when he went
on national television but even when he
did the decision everyone gave him [ __ ]
for it
he raised like a million bucks or
something and gave it all charity yeah
he started a school like I just think
he's like a good deal who has navigated
the pressure of being the best
basketball player in the world right now
better than 99.9% of people could do it
and so now he started to use this voice
to do things outside of basketball which
looks some people may not like what he's
doing this organizations called more
than a vote and it'll partly be aimed at
inspiring African American citizens to
register and cast the ballot in November
do you think that LeBron James has
political ambitions no you don't think
so
no why zero why because I don't think
like somebody like LeBron James say they
like Michael Jordan like they're
actually more influential outside of
politics than in politics right right
you're just an you just have one vote
but like when the Bron James comes out
and says some things like when Joe Rogan
came out said he was gonna vote for one
candidate or another freaks out so I
being outside the system you probably
have more influence than actually being
a part of the system would you ever run
for president no that's like literally
uh do you want to take decades off your
life in a matter of four years oh yeah
you'd freak out if you got like a
wrinkle be like oh this is because no
it's just you basically go and you argue
with people over things that ultimately
the president doesn't even have control
over for the most part and we need
better leadership across all levels of
government but again I tend to think
that the people who have the ability to
influence political direction and
leadership outside the system are much
more effective than the people who have
to play within the system yeah I agree
what's going on facial recognition
software Amazon said that it was putting
a one-year pause on letting the police
use its facial recognition tool in a
major sign of the growing concerns of
the technology may lead to unfair
treatment of african-americans
what is this facial recognition tool
that Amazon has well let's back up for a
second so facial recognition software
for those that don't know is literally a
camera that can look and it can tell you
this is plana this is me whatever it's
been hotly hotly debated across the
Europe and the u.s. using this
technology in a law enforcement capacity
so for example if you walk outside there
could be the potential that the police
are using facial recognition software
let's say on the street in Manhattan and
they're trying to find a criminal which
sounds like a great idea oh cool we're
gonna use this to detect the criminals
but if I'm a law-abiding private citizen
and I'm walking down the street one
you're not telling me that you're doing
this so I have no knowledge of it
- I didn't consent to you taking my
biometrics like the scan of my face
three is that then in many cases
especially the UK they're not allowed to
keep DNA and fingerprint information
forever you have to basically there's a
like a shelf life for it and if it's not
used to help convict somebody of a crime
then they have to dispose of it but
facial recognition software doesn't fall
under those rules as of right now so
they can miss they keep that database of
faces forever which is a huge concern
then the last piece is what this is
talking about which is there's a bunch
of studies that show the current forms
of facial recognition software
disproportionately misidentified so it's
skewed and misidentifies women and
african-americans in the facial
recognition software so bizarre well
some people would argue okay that is us
writing software that shows the human
bias so humans are biased we write the
software read software then is a
representation because the way we write
it and it's kind of like the unconscious
bias tough there's another argument to
be made that some people would argue
well men have much more prominent
features in their face and so if you
look at things in many cases there's
like twelve or sixteen points on the
face of the software measures and so if
it's easier to detect because there's
more prominent features then you'll have
a higher degree of accuracy I would
argue I have some prominent features but
anybody
another argument would be no the
training data that they feed into the
software has more male faces than
females another there's a bunch of
complexity heroes because one is a race
the other is a gender if that if what
you're saying is true about the
prominent features it would mean that
african-american men would be fine to be
identified of course so like there's a
bunch of complexities here basically
what's happened is there's two things
iBM has said they're going to shut down
their facial recognition work all of
their kind of general application facial
recognition amazon's putting a pause for
one year on it being used by law
enforcement i wrote about it this
morning
IBM this is a little bit of a cop-out
supposedly they were drastically behind
Amazon on their technology and so like
what better way to bow out of the market
and save face then oh we're doing it for
civil rights reasons right Amazon
however is saying look we're gonna
continue to develop the technology we're
not gonna allow the police to use it for
a year and what both companies are
calling on is for Congress and lawmakers
to put in place rules around who can
create this technology how is it audited
to make sure it's accurate and
non-discriminatory who has access to the
information how long can you keep it
another thing would be something like
let's say I walk down the street and my
face is scanned through facial
recognition either through the police or
whatever should they have to communicate
that to me should they have to send me
an email and say hey today between the
hours of you know 12:00 and 4:00 p.m.
while walking on Third Avenue you're
faced with it it's just it's just the
fact that you have to communicate people
know I know I understand but what's the
point of that if you're never consented
to it they send you an email they say we
saw you on 3rd Avenue what are you gonna
do about it they're to scan you of
course so like that that might not be a
good solution right there's all of these
questions about like what is the right
solution I don't think that Congress
knows yet but they are looking like
they're gonna take this on and go and
try to get out yeah I went to a
conference in China where they very much
did fee shares kind of freaky to be
honest it was just like you walk through
and it immediately like pulls up all
your information it was pretty crazy
yeah they will they do it in the
airports right they tell you where they
basically use facial recognition
software to tell you which I consented
to you're going to gate see 15 go right
right and then make a left and you're
like wait how do you even know who I am
yeah
all right what's going on with Twitter
who supposedly does not use facial
recognition software Twitter what the
hell is Twitter doing I'm just like very
confused by it at the moment but Twitter
is testing a new prompt for retweets so
basically when you retweet a link to an
article but you didn't click the link
before retweeting a message is gonna pop
up saying hey it looks like you haven't
read this article let me ask if you want
to open it first before you retweet it
I'm fine with it it's just I think it's
a deterrent or sorry not a deterrent I
think this is actually a bad move for
Twitter if you look at it from Twitter
business perspective it's a much better
improvement on a societal impact but my
question is how many people are really
gonna be like like click the X button or
how many people are gonna be like wow
let me sit down and read this article
yeah there's a bunch of studies that
show simply prompting people will deter
a certain number people from retweeting
it without reading that's I mean that's
great if you guys can read the headlines
and the articles that'd be nice because
whitter also has one where if you go to
say something like really mean or
profanity or whatever supposedly there's
some people who are in a testing group
on twitter that will get a prompt that
says are you sure you want to tweet this
or like you know please be kind to
people below whatever so you're saying
that this actually helps yeah I mean
look think about it it's like anything
in the world if you get people to think
about what they're gonna do or say
before they do it it's likely that
they're going to act like better actors
I hope so
right do you know who likes this who
guess who
Elon Musk was a great idea this is yeah
I mean look it's it's a weird thing
we're like the academic research is like
pretty compelling that everyone should
be doing this so we see home is twice
before you do something yeah and it's
just saying like hey if you're gonna
retweet this that's fine you can do
without reading it so not stopping you
from doing it they're just like ASCII
they're putting friction in the way
which is a that actually hurts the
business case and the user metric case
but
if it's better for society it's kind of
a long-term play for Twitter to do the
right thing that's fair that's alright I
like it jackpot what's up okay
bang bang jackpot get money get paid
okay don't look someone in Arizona won
the 410 million dollar Mega Millions
jackpot guess how big the tax bill is
fifteen million dollars more than that
how much so federal tax will reduce that
by seventy six million in state taxes
will shave off another fifteen point two
million so basically they're going wrong
I got the state tax that's because I
looked at so what they gotta pay ninety
million dollar tax bill so they got they
walk away three hundred and sixteen for
a neat line which is not bad yeah I mean
look the federal government's gonna get
their money the state's gonna get their
money that's fine but the person's gonna
get rich get paid oh wait no get money
get oh my god I butchered my own fish
sorry do you play the the jackpot
lottery nobody okay do you want to hear
a crazy story oh my god this is the
craziest no I'm speaking for the people
we don't wanna hear no we want to hear
it guys okay so when I was a little I
don't know what it was for but like my
aunt was like here fill out this little
like lot or anything and so I did so I
did with like I did all the numbers that
were like my family's birth dates so I
did like 24 for me 16 for my aunt
whatever and I won five out of six which
at like five numbers out of six which in
Bulgaria at the time you got like a lot
of money but they didn't want to give us
the money because the very end no
because it spoke area and didn't want to
do that they claimed that the 16 was a
little bit smudge so you couldn't
exactly tell if it was a sixteen so they
gave us the tiniest the tinier prize a
four out of six but I got five out of
six well actually you got four to six
according to the judges so stupid well
right clear that's that's a personal
responsibility if you took personal
responsibility for your mistakes then
you could say hey next time I will write
much clearly
it was a clear 16 powdery probably like
seven oh maybe we shouldn't have seven
year-olds filling our lottery tickets up
maybe we should be a shock
I know play those and I'll have a
conversation with ya
oh she of all people was alright any
last words for the people I feel like
we've done a great job eighteen minutes
no messages for the people no be kind
yes be kind especially now to a friend
should they all go play the jackpot yeah
yeah all right get money get paid while
while she's trying to get rich that's
nice just trying to get our lunch money
right go subscribe to the channel like
the video and there is a link to the
email if you want us to send the video
every day when it gets posted so you
don't have to go to youtube to find it
sign up for the email it's pinned in the
comments go do it now we'll see you
tomorrow
do you think people can call me
Pollyanna Jacquemont Mironova
what's wrong with you bang-bang hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of lunch money
as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block 5 so go check them out there's
a link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina
they've got 3 products they can give you
a u.s. dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block bye
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy playing in the comment and we'll
see you guys tomorrow and be kind to
your friends